I ne I never claimed that um Allah is
the God of the Bible.
>> The the crown it
>> does it?
>> Yeah. It says that the same aloh sent
down the crown sent down the scriptures
after
>> the which you know that that
>> Arabic is in jail, right?
>> Yeah. But you don't want to go there
assuming that the injil is not the New
Testament. I promise you don't want to
go there
>> because
>> Okay. We we we can if you want to. We
can.
>> Okay. Now you said the
>> sounds interesting.
>> Okay, here let's do it.
>> Okay, let's let me show you.
>> Let's go to the in. And then what is the
Torah according to you?
The Quran mentions
>> revelation given to MS.
>> Okay, I'm going to give you $100,000
and I'll have everyone take shahada if
you can show me in the Quran. It says
the Torah was given to MS in the Quran.
I told you you don't want to go there,
but you insisted.
I'll give you $100,000
which I don't have and everyone who's
going to become Muslim show me a single
verse says and we gave the Torah to Mus
don't show me a verse where it says we
gave MS the book is not the same as
Torah and even
>> okay
>> Islamic sources
the
said that the word Torah doesn't just
mean the books of Moses it refers to the
scriptures of the two the two scriptures
of the people of the book so where did
you get that the Torah was given to
Moses can you show me the verse in the
Quran
Not off the top of my head. No,
>> it's not there.
>> Okay.
>> I'm telling you, and I'm going to prove
it to you. It's not there, but I don't
know why it doesn't come.
>> So, you So, so you think that when the
when the Quran says TRA, it's referring
literally to the Old Testament.
>> I'm not saying that. Your Muslim
translators admit this because I'm going
to quote them in a minute.
So, that's why you don't know much. You
just came into the faith. You're green.
Hopefully, by the grace of God, you're
going to end up leaving. But before I do
that here, let's go with injil because
it's singular, not an never heard that
one before. All right, let's read Maida
546 to 47. And in their footsteps, we
sent Isa son of Miam confirming the
Torat Torah that had come before him.
That's not the literal translation, but
we'll get to that. And we gave him the
in which was guidance and light and a
confirmation of Torat that had come
before it. A guidance and admonition for
mut. But then it says, watch verse 47.
So there's my question to you now.
Muhammad is addressing his
contemporaries. Let the people of the
gospel judge by what Allah has revealed
therein. What did they have at the time
of Muhammad?
>> How you going to judge if you don't have
it at the time of because it's saying
look Jesus came with the gospel. You
people the gospel judge by it. Judge by
what?
I don't know.
>> Yeah, because the Muslims who taught you
didn't teach you. Well, you have to
learn on your own. I know because I've
been there, done that because they tried
to convert me too in the 90s. But the
Lord of God, he saved me. So when you
say the is
whatever it is, it's not the New
Testament. How do you know that? When
here it says whatever the angel is, it
was at the time of Muhammad. The
Christians had it. And if you want more
proof here 7157
they're now going to identify the angel
for you watch they're going to do it not
me those who follow the messenger the
prophet who can neither read nor write
whom they find written with them it's
with them in the Torah and the and what
did they identify the here as
what's in here they gave it to you in
>> I don't know what what is That's a Bible
verse. What is that verse?
>> See, that's why you got to read the
Bible. John 14 verse 16. So I thought,
hold on.
>> And this is the halali.
>> Yeah. Alihan translation. That's what
I'm using right here.
>> Khan here. So
>> you see it right here. Alihan.
>> And right here.
>> So they're telling you this prophecy of
this unlettered prophet is a ninj. And
they say, "Well, that's the Gospel of
John 14:16." So, wait, didn't you try to
somehow deny that? That the gospel is
not what I have. It's not the New
Testament. How do you know that?
>> What is what is what is that? 616.
>> Chapter 14 verse 16. This is Roman
numeral 101.
>> Okay. I means 14 verse 16. Prophecy of
the pariclete.
>> And here Deuteronomy 18:15, a prophet
like Moses. But my point is they're
telling me that the gospel that's with
the Christians Christians is the gospel
of John. Why did they tell me that?
>> I don't know. You have to ask them. I
mean, it's, you know, it's not in
Arabic. So, it's not really
>> No, because they're they realize that
the Quran is not a fraud. What you're
trying to accuse it of. Whatever the
gospel is, it was there at their at
their possession. So, historically.
>> So, did you did you just say I was
trying to say that the Quran is a fraud?
>> No. If you do not answer, then you're
accusing the Quran of because the Quran
is saying the gospel is there at the
time Muhammad. So they're being faithful
to history and saying, "Well, hold on.
Historically,
the only gospel that Christians have is
the New Testament scripture." So forget
them. What did they have at time
Muhammad? I'm still waiting for your
answer.
>> Well, okay. So the verse says, "Let the
people of the gospel judge by what Allah
has revealed therein."
>> Therein what?
I mean that does that necessarily imply
that they
that they have an the
>> so what are they going to judge by
>> the untouched gospel
>> or the
>> what are they going to judge by read the
context context is 46 47 immutil
>> how they going to judge by the if they
don't have it
>> they may not I don't I don't know
>> so how they your god is telling them
judge by it how wait Allah Wait, we
don't have it. Remember, you're not
answering the question.
>> I mean, maybe maybe they have uh part of
it.
>> And what does it say? They have part of
it here.
>> I'm just saying that's a possibility
>> to the Quran, which you're condemned for
doing.
>> I'm just saying that's a possibility.
Can that be a possibility that they they
have part of it, but they don't?
>> Anything can be possible. It's even
possible that Muhammad was a Hindu.
What's possible doesn't make it
probable. I want you to help me identify
what the gospel is at the time of Jesus.
Muhammad, I'm sorry. I'm still waiting,
man.
>> Yeah, I don't know. I'll have to get
back to you on it.
>> Okay.
>> And then here it says, "Those who follow
the messenger prophet who can neither
read nor write whom they find written
with them in the Torah and the G." So
again, it's talking about time Muhammad,
they had to turn the gospel. So help me
understand what gospel did they have at
the time Muhammad where Muslims could
say, "Hey, Muhammad is there in your
gospel.
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Like I said, I have to get back to
you. I don't
>> That's why I'm saying don't come to me
and say untainted gospel because I know
you bought the dais script. The
scriptures are corrupt. The Quran
nowhere says they're corrupt. It says
they're perfectly preserved. I know the
verses that they've taught you. Surah al
Bakar 275, 279, 378, 548. None of that
proves their point because I've debated
that issue. Put that aside. I want to
again ask you what made you think that
the God of the Quran is the same God of
the prophets mentioned in the scriptures
because it talks about
the prophets who are given scriptures
before Muhammad and Muhammad comes in
their succession and it's supposed to be
the same God. How is it the same God?
>> I don't I'm not sure it is the the
script. I don't I don't think we have
enough evidence to prove that the
scriptures we have today are this have
have been preserved.
>> Well, that means the Quran is now
bearing false witness because it says
they have been preserved. But if you're
going
>> Yeah, it does.
>> Verse verse after verse.
>> Look at that.
>> Oh, sure. My pleasure.
>> Here you go. I have articles, but I'm
going to show it to you. So then if
you're consistent, you have no proof
that your Quran is perfectly preserved
because the manuscripts and your
traditions say the Quran is corrupted.
You don't even have one Arabic version
of the Quran. You have various and
they're missing suras. That's according
to your Islamic sources. So I'm still
wondering why are you a Muslim? But hold
on, we'll get there. Let me just go
there. We'll get there. One second.
So the for the reasons for you to become
a Muslim are not sound and the reasons
for you rejecting Christianity are not
sound either. But be that as it may.
Hold on, brother. Let me just line it up
for you so that you know 136. All right.
One second. All right.
>> You got this all memorized or you got
this written down?
>> That's the gift of the Holy Spirit. The
true spirit of the true God. May he be
glorified and through me to bring Christ
glory. Yep, I do. But anyway, 240 to 44.
240 to 44. Let me show it right here. Oh
children of Israel, remember my favor
which I bestowed upon you and fulfill
your obligations to my covenant so that
I fulfill my oblations to your covenant.
Now remember the comments in parentheses
brackets are not part of the Arabic, but
put that aside. And fear none but me and
believe in what I have sent down this
Quran confirming that which is with you.
Present tense. He's talking to his
audience. This confirms what is with you
and then they tell you we can ignore it.
The Torah and the Inel is with you and
the Quran confirms
what you have. Not opposes and say
they're corrupt and be not the first to
disbelieve therein. and buy not buy not
with my verses toward a small price of
getting a small gain by selling my
verses and fear me and fear me alone and
mix not truth with falsehood nor conceal
the truth and they put in parenthesis
Muhammad qualities in the gospel while
you know you know the truth now real
quickly before I finish it says do not
conceal the truth while you know the
truth if you don't have the truth can
you conceal
No,
>> but then here it says they're concealing
the truth. So that means they must have
it. Right.
>> Right.
>> Okay. Just want you to keep in mind,
don't forget what you're telling me. And
perform a salah and give zakat and they
have to always give Arabic words along
with
what is it
now? 44
>> enjoin
you
piety and righteousness in every act of
disobed obedience to Allah and you
forget to practice it yourselves while
you recite the scripture. Okay, before I
move on because I want you to pay
attention. They're reciting the
scripture.
They have the truth though they conceal
it. And the Quran confirms what they
already have, not what they used to
have, what you have now. How are they
going to recite the scripture,
>> conceal the truth, and why would the
Quran confirm what they have? If you are
correct, their scriptures are corrupt
and not reliable.
>> Well, just because they're corrupt
doesn't mean that they can't contain the
truth. And I don't see anything so far
saying that
>> this is now the third time you interpret
the Quran for me. And it doesn't say
what you say because the verb confirm
means to bear witness to the veracity
and the honesty and the truthfulness of
a thing or person.
>> That's where you get
sodak. Why is the Quran not reading the
way you're interpreting it?
>> Well, you're also interpreting it when
you're reading it saying that it's
>> No, I'm just telling you what's in front
of me here. Can you show me it says
confirming only parts of what you have
or does it say confirming that which is
with you? Can you show me who's reading
it as it appears and who's interpreting
it?
>> It but it also doesn't say confirming
all of that which is with you.
>> So
if I show you where it says John the
Baptist confirms a word from Allah, but
it doesn't say it confirms all of
Allah's word. So your logic means he
only confirms a part of it.
>> Yeah, that's a possibility. Yeah. Then
that means you just said that John
didn't bear witness to Jesus being fully
reliable and you just blasphemed and
you're a kafir. See, think before you
speak.
>> Yes. Can you repeat again?
>> Okay. You just ended up kufur because
the verb chapter 39 says confirms a word
from Allah. And I said, "So doesn't mean
he confirms all of it." You go, "Yeah,
that's possible." But the word of Allah
is Jesus. Are you saying that John is
saying, "Yeah, there are some things
about Jesus that are right, but there
may be some things about him that aren't
right." Think before you say
>> both both are both both are possible. He
could be confirming part or he could be
confirmed.
>> How can he be confirming only a part of
Jesus and his mission?
>> I'm not saying he was. I'm just saying
grammatically that
>> No. Not at all. The burden of proof is
on you to show it's only confirming a
part of it. Where don't make
>> I didn't say I didn't say I didn't say
that he's only confirming a part of I'm
saying grammatically that
>> where in the grammar show it to me that
it means only a part not all of it. I'm
waiting
>> I'd have to give you a separate example
to for it to make sense.
>> Give me an example. Can you give me any
Arabic lexicans
or even
>> lexican?
Can you give me anything or you're just
say
>> what are you talking about sedaka? Why
did you mention that? Because the word
here is
confirming
like
>> or when you give sodaka.
All right. So let's
>> I mean I mean if you have a if you have
a say if you have a
>> collection of
facts and some of them are true and some
of them are not true and then I tell
somebody yeah I I agree with what he
says. That doesn't mean I agree with
everything that you say. You could still
>> You don't qualify it. I would take it to
mean you agree with everything I say.
No, you're wrong. You would have to
qualify your statement.
>> I wouldn't have to. I wouldn't have to,
though.
>> Yes, you would. If you say I agree with
what he says and you full stop, then
you're going to leave me with the
impression that what he says, you have
no fault with it.
>> Give me a better.
>> I don't I don't I don't Another example.
>> Yeah, that's based on a little on the
spot. Let me give me give me a second to
to try and think of another example.
>> Yeah.
>> All right.
>> Um
>> Yeah. Mhm.
>> You need to shut down your YouTube
channel, brother. You'd have no business
talking about the Quran of the Bible.
Honestly,
now as you're thinking about coming up
with some examples to tap dance here,
chapter 2,
>> I I don't think I need to give another
example. I I think I've already said
what I
>> Yeah. Sorry. Well, let's
>> what I think what I said makes sense, I
think, so we can agree because you're
the standard again. It didn't feel right
to me. This made sense to me because you
are God and the standard of truth. Yeah,
we got that already. But I'm just going
to let the Quran show you that you're
not the standard and even as a Muslim,
Allah is your standard. But even here,
you have to negotiate with Allah and
tell Allah he could have said it in a
better way. Well, that's
>> okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Imagine.
>> Okay.
Before you give me your uh spiel, let's
read the Quran 289.
>> Well, there came to them.
>> That's okay. Yeah, sure.
>> Well, hold on. Read. when there came to
them the Jews a book from Allah
confirming what is with them. Now let's
follow your logic here. The Quran is
saying the proof for the Jews and the
Christians that the Quran is from God is
that the Quran is going to confirm part
of their scripture but not all of it.
And you think the Jews are going to now
be convinced, oh thank you. Now we know
you're from from God because you're
saying only part of our scripture is
intact. The other is corrupt. And that's
going to make us believe you're a
prophet. That's the argument of this
passage.